en las líneas de desempleo
y ese trabajo me permitió apoyar a su
familia y criar a mi madre y enviarle a
la universidad y ese es el sueño
estadounidense juntos trabajamos juntos
nos levantamos joe biden en cámara
harris conocen la dignidad de todos los
estadounidenses trabajadores y que saben
de la urgencia de nuestros sueños las
personas trabajadoras están bajo ataque
a la brecha de riqueza crece y la
pobreza persiste la semana pasada donald
trump dijo y sitios de nuestra economía
está muy bien mientras que 40 millones
de estadounidenses están en riesgo de
perder sus hogares 30 millones si no
tienen suficiente para comer y 5.4
millones de personas han perdido su
servicio de salud por culpa de esta
crisis
él ha fallado nos ha fallado pero aún
así tú y yo creo en el sueño de nuestros
ancestros
con joe y camada en la casa blanca
el salario mínimo para que cualquier
persona que trabaje en eeuu nadie puede
vivir en la pobreza juntos
lucharemos por aquellos que nos
mantienen saludables que nos mantienen
seguros que enseñan a nuestros hijos nos
levantaremos por aquellos que cocinan y
sirven y limpian
aquellos que
empaca y plantan aquellos que entregan
cuyas manos están llenas de callos como
las de mi abuelo quien me levantaba alto
cuando yo era un pequeño niño y vos si
estuviese vivo yo
él estaría tan orgulloso de ustedes y
toma a otro y a otro por la mano y ya
vamos a trabajar si quiere ser libre
tienes que trabajar por eso como su
generación nosotros saliendo desde la
depresión ahora trabajemos juntos y
mantengamos los juntos y eeuu juntos
vamos a levantarnos